citizens of the reject Nation hello my
name is Aaron Alexander and this is Mr
Andrew Gordon how you doing Andrew I am
doing well I'm ready to be spooked oo
spooky season for the Halloween time
today we're watching 28 Days Later a
zombie movie neither him or I have seen
and I know nothing about it what do you
know about this I know that Killian
Murphy is in it and that's it Killian
Murphy Mr Oppenheimer himself Mr
scarecrow himself come on let's give him
his Dark Knight trilogy Vibes that we
owe him wearing a Batman shirt how you
scarecrow I know I know shame on me dang
it dity dang you guys leave a like on
this video we're going to have a great
ass time for you people watching at home
would you want to watch the full length
thing with us full length Reaction watch
along sing up with your own copy at home
for you super sexy rejects out there
John and Greg cover several shows at
patreon.com theal rejects exclusive
exclusively with reaction highlights and
wash alongs included okay guys I hope
you're ready hope you're ready for this
magical experience and uh yeah some me
and Andrew video baby it's the first
time doing it so let's get it yes all
right get
ready RP I apologize if I get loud on
some of these scares it's okay oh [__]
yep all right we're
here is this last of us before last of
us
it's giving those vibes for sure oh
God what is this 2020 that's a great
transition out of the TV there wow I
like that I like
that what the hell is
that oh it's a gorilla being forced to
watch Humanity's trauma good God no it's
a
chimp than
go
reminds me of pogo oh
no oh there's a bunch of
them oh is this the alternative Universe
to Planet of the
Apes
oh my God there's a freaking monkey head
in there oh my
God I know what you think you're doing
you don't want to get H keep your mouth
shut and don't move a muscle The Chimps
are infected oh no oh God infected with
what rage what the is talking about for
this [__] get the cages open oh no if
they're infected oh you dummies I
they're Freedom Fighters so they want to
help them but they're really do in
humanity one
but you have no
idea that's vicious oh my
God oh God oh no I hate this oh
Jesus
ah oh
God yo not in the face dude no way oh
she's uh she's finished
already oh my God that was scary open 28
Days Later the title of the movie guys
roll credits that was a freaky
opening okay is that is that Killian eye
looks like a Killian eye but we shall
see definitely a kilan eye look at that
oh god what the hell AIT is that what he
was talking about I think that's what
Greg was talking about it's his
Oppenheimer Kean put your Murphy away
dog this reminds me of of Rick Grimes
from Walking Dead
Carl
hello this cinematography the way it's
filmed I just want to know what's the
why are they leaving him just like butt
ass naked in the hospital like no gowns
you don't got gowns okay he is closed
now but who was like let's just leave
him just like gout open you know were
they operating on him like what the
what's the deal
guys
hello the fireflies hav't shown up yet
okay product
placement never came out of a man was
like oh damn I need a a freaking
Pepsi hey if they're going to put up
some of the budget you got to take care
of them right
W is this L where are
we maybe is oh this is the UK yeah it's
London what was this guy going
through I wouldn't be shocked if um they
took some inspiration when they made
last of us from this film cuz I'm I'm
getting some Vibes feel same the the
music is very similar as well yeah
exactly I was thinking that too but this
obviously came out way before way before
last of us
hello you imagine just walking through
an actual City and there's nothing going
on I mean it's like nice in terms of
going to get somewhere but also freaky
at the same point it is it's Eerie
that's how that's all it was during Co
do remember that like in LA I was like
driving places I'm like this is awesome
in terms of traffic but it's like you
said it's Eerie at the same point it was
so nice like I could go anywhere and get
anywhere
soace is that an infected uh wound yeah
be well I mean we did see I I guess it
maybe I don't know the rules of this
world yet but we did see with the the
character who got infected by the monkey
that she got turned pretty quickly but
also was a bite to the neck so I don't
know if maybe in the arm it takes longer
so yeah or maybe he had the um the IV
still in his arm that cured it may I I
don't
[Music]
know I'm actually really digging the
cinematography so far it's interesting
yeah same gives you like almost like to
a claustrophobic zombes feel just
realized in this moment I don't think
I've ever seen kilan Murphy with a beard
before um I have quiet quiet place too
oh you're right
another you got me there you got him you
got me there the zombies haven't even
started yet yeah seriously if a if a car
alarm gets me I'm I'm I'm done for the
rest of the film I mean hey if it was
real life it would get me too
[__] you know what this reminds me of
too again obviously this came out out
way before Avengers endgame when Ant-Man
is discovering like totally y yeah that
must have been inspiration for this
scene 100% what is
happening so if you woke up like he did
and you knew there was nobody there
would you still walk around with clothes
on probably still mosquitoes or other
things to protect yourself
from extremely not
the End is Extremely Nigh
okay
yeah oh my goodness jeez are those dead
people that's what it looks like oh no
unless he went to a haunted house that
was
abandoned this is heavy dude in the
Flies too it's Marty McFly used to
say
[Music]
hello get
the oh no no no no no
no dude get out of there hell no hell
no bro you better you better hit her
with that bag or something or just run
yeah but what's in that bag is it
supplies father normally in movies and
shows there's slow are they fast here
okay oh no they're fast father are you
okay I'm pretty sure he's not dude like
that's
right oh I shouldn't have done
that shouldn't have done that you're
going to hell now you hit the you hit
the dead priest you're going to hell
congratulations that makeup is really
good it is really
[Music]
good yeah I love the way it's shot well
gives you a sense like you're almost
there literally with him too mhm
God every
noise oh fre Freedom
Fighters they going to run into the gas
[Music]
station keep going [__] going just shut
up feel like an explosion is about to
happen this is
wild boom
yeah okay that one got
me
damn wow wow wow wow I love that that
wide angle shot that shows us the scope
of the explosion great that was pretty
cool did that too in Dark Knight and
RoboCop when they get those wide big
explosion shots this is why he's here he
know he knows stuff he catches all the
things sometimes sometimes man walks
into a bar with a giraffe hey get pissed
giraffe Falls over the man goes to leave
OB says o you can't leave that lion
there he says no it's not a lion it's a
giraffe what so who are you we are from
a hospital yeah is that he's not a
doctor he's a patient I can't tell I'm a
bicycle carrier he a bicycle carrier
he's just a guy I was writing a package
from uh farington to Shaftsbury Avenue
and a carac across me and then I wake up
today in hospital I wake up and what's
your name Jim I'm Mark this is Selena
can't tell
that it was happening in small villages
Market towns and then it wasn't on the
TV anymore it was in the street outside
it was coming through your windows it
was a virus wol Something In The Blood
by the time they tried to evacuate the
cities it was already too late the Army
blades were overrun and that's when the
exra started spread like wildfire yeah
well it would in real life so yeah what
about the government what are they doing
there's no government of course there's
a government there's always a government
they're in a a bunker or a
plane you're the first uninfected person
we've seen in six days wow was your
family they're dead like Selena's yours
will be dead too they're living de for I
can walk it okay well you'll go and come
back yeah careful hey chill out drink a
Pepsi come on guys
get a grip you never go anywhere alone
unless you got no choice un l two only
travel during daylight never say you'll
be right back take you
tomorrow we'll all go and find your dead
parents together okay it's going to say
the horror movie rules never say you'll
be right back this is this is one of the
rules or split up never split up makes
sense though that nighttime is I mean we
also learned that too in I Am Legend it
came out after this technically the book
came out before oh right right right and
also the
Omega Man right man Charlton h
m this music is giving me Vibes of is
The Dark Knight Rises like yeah in the
football stadium yeah yeah yeah yeah it
was actually uh Pittsburgh Steelers
Stadium hindes Field hin Stadium thing
what a lovely lovely voice that's pretty
good actually oh thank thank you eron I
appreciate it you're welcome Andrew I
took over for Heath leer and for the
Scarecrow and
R oh no
no oh man that's oh this is so sad
actually this reminds me of Last of Us
yeah episode three yeah exactly Bill and
Frank yeah man as I'm watching this I
realized how like infuential this
influential this was for Last of Us for
sure for a lot of zombie properties yeah
I would I can I mean we're only a half
hour in I can understand why
yeah is this the one Zack snd directed
no he did not I don't believe he direct
oh that's Don of the Dead yeah yeah I
haven't seen that either I haven't I
haven't seen that either we should stay
here tonight my room is up the top you
two going to have to stay no we'll all
sleep in the same room it's safer yeah
man when when Global tragedy strikes
it's it's crazy crazy though I me see
what people Humanity becomes and also
when it's something like there's no
Escape I mean you can do your best to
fight it off but there's no escaping
like you can't take a flight somewhere
or do something like that I mean no it's
everywhere yeah yeah
man cool
transition with the TV one then this one
I mean you got shots you're real sad but
you got some shots on
you I would definitely not be able to
sleep after discover oh hell no you just
woke up too you know what I would be
able to do what drink a Pepsi I would
definitely drink a
Pepsi take take back like like six
Pepsis get Pepsi
wasted a this is so sad
dude just the image of like that guy
shoots to St oh
man are you back yeah
straight from the carton like a
Savage you may drink it out will
you it's
empty oh no is the zombie seeing
it no fight
[Music]
fight
a o
machete dude you can't turn on lights
bro did they explain that Ru I forgot I
know they said stick together oh he' be
cutting his hand wide open on that
glass were you a
bitten did any of the blood get in your
mouth I hate it wait are going to kill
mark oh
no Jesus oh that's his fault too did she
kill him or just cut his arm off I
couldn't tell it looked like it was more
than that get dressed we have to leave
now she murdered that guy she murdered
the hell of that guy look if someone
gets infected you've got between 10 and
20 seconds to kill them it might be your
brother or your sister or your oldest
friend it makes no difference that
sounds like foreshadow for her I was
just going to say the same thing so you
know where you stand if it happens to
you I'll do it in a heartbeat and he's
not going to want to do it and she's
going to turn he's going to have no
choice do you want us to find a cure and
save the world or just fall in love
and not a bad plant I mean just go to a
farm somewhere you guys could live a
good life he looks extremely
unhealthy skinny yeah I was thinking the
same maybe it's just the hood I think
it's just the beanie the beanie makes
him look extra skinny extra Jesse
Pinkman you got to give props to the uh
set design team the production design
it's phenomenal so far in this film no
truly do you need a
break you no I just need a
Pepsi now I do need a
break Pepsi break it's the energy drink
I need got a headache well why didn't
you say something before well because I
didn't think you'd give a [__] you got
no fat on you and all you've had to eat
is
sugar yeah dude so pump you full of
painkillers and give you more sugar as
for
sugar
Pepsi I was just saying it as a joke I
didn't think we were actually going
there
yes quiet that's an infected
sure enough but they I mean can they get
oh they're fast they're fast now fast
yeah it's like Runners and Last of Us
fast there's different classes or
different kinds of them wait for me
please flashlight on a stick wait for me
she ain't waiting for your ass bro she's
gone I mean yeah it's every person for
themselves when they're coming after you
she's you saying B my guy she's got it
there oo down the corridor flat 157 yay
[Applause]
[Music]
ooh Open Door where's that
[Applause]
[Music]
what this is really intense yeah cuz I'm
even cuz like in most zombie things you
know who do you who can you trust you
know even even the humans are
monsters so oh is that Brandon gleon is
that m i moody this is my daughter H
come on sweetheart say hello where's
Harry
Potter yeah when you don't trim and you
use a blade like that that's going to
hurt badly like really bad do you know
from experience I've done that before
yes that Hur
we have a spare
room in there are you and Selena going
to smash no no no no I'll take the the
living room it's fine are you going to
bump uglies you can if you want to I
mean got a spare room so what do you
make of them well they're desperate
probably need us more than we need them
I think they're good
people last is
wife you should be more concerned about
whether they're going to slow you down
right because if they slowed you down i'
leave them behind in a happy yeah
clearly she would cuz she almost left
our guy over here lost water pressure 3
weeks ago for a while I thought we'd be
okay with the water and the other flats
systems and
tanks who it well I mean you got to have
a way to have get water yeah smart all
empty hasn't rained in 10 days ah you
can set up a plastic sheet to catch Ste
and condensation trap it somehow a smart
you never think it needing rain so badly
not in
England I feel like those basket are not
going to be very helpful you see the the
basket with all the holes like a laundry
basket uhuh why is that there who's that
for there haven't been any broadcast for
weeks just listen the answer to
infection is here if you hear this
you're not alone where are they We Are
Soldiers and oh my God location is the
42 blockade the m602 27 mil Northeast of
Manchester what what a recording yeah
it's a recording if it's a recording for
all we know the soldiers who made it are
dead that's a good point yeah it's risky
well the only way to find out is to
reach we could die trying Frank or die
here I mean they're going to run out of
water soon anyways yeah we need each
other and we'll never be safe in the
cities the soldiers could keep us safe
so we have to try and get there if it's
not a trap get there
how oh wow oh I thought it was a tank at
first well they're only going to have a
limited amount of gas so true what you
think it's the most direct route to the
other side of the river then we should
take the indirect route the one that's
in broad daylight and that's not
underground let's just get it done I
would not go through that tunnel not a
smart idea guys but then the other flip
side is you're going to run out of gas
faster taking the longer but then you
don't face I these are tough decisions
but I would not go through that that
tunnel no no yeah they both have their
pros and cons but this is a yeah hell no
CU it's really obviously a [__] idea so
at least they're acknowledging it's a
[__] idea I mean Matt R has a point
obviously a [__] idea hold
on
[Applause]
o h
ah that was not smart that was freaking
dummy why would you why would you do
that world's worst place to get a flat
huh agreed think we better do this quick
I mean you guys got a a whole sea of
cars you guys could pick from to get
another tire if you needed it and you're
going to be making noise as well true a
got no guns either cuz they don't have
guns in the UK they have little they
have knives and machetes hey
J I've done it
dad uhoh God uhoh are those
rats no no no no no no no are they
normal rats or zombie rats oh oh oh
God I think
there
uh-oh running from the infected that's
what I had a feeling even the rats are
scared of the infected wow there's no
time forget the Jack just lift everyone
gra home
drop it
[Music]
drive that might have been a world
record I've ever seen for fastest spare
tire seriously but I'm glad they did in
record
time
[Music]
wow you know where they're head to of
course we know straight to straight to
the
[Laughter]
Pepsi moldy everything is moldy except
for these
apples it don't take anything that needs
to be cooked okay I was going to say
yeah anything that needs to be cooked
you can't
take yeah and that can come in handy if
they need a mult cocktail too
yeah either we do this now or we're
walking stay close Jim oh okay they're
going to take it out of the gas thing
can put it into the oh yeah that'd be
smart siph in it exactly yeah where's
your uh don't you need the tube for that
you need to like suck it a little bit oh
they got the tube too
cool gross I would have waited until
like we were ready to go though to go
into a place like this that's has no
lights in it if you're going to try and
get something like this like until
you're fully ready to go this is not the
smartest move in my
opinion ah damn I really would not be in
there right
now all died where they dude get out of
there you just called how crappy it was
that you stupid it was that you were
driving in that tunnel get out of there
hello you
dumbass dude you have to it's a k you
have to do it it's still a
zombie oh it sucks it was a kid kid but
you had no choice find anything Jim no
let's get out of here was that his first
kill of the movie uh maybe cuz I think
she she had to she had to help him
before Oh my
God I like taste vit see this must feel
so normal for them right now in such a
not normal time I like how balanced this
movie feels it if you notice it
alternates between like a scary scene
and a peaceful like uplifting
scene in the scenes that are not scary
like you're still aware of like anything
can change at any moment right you have
this sense of danger if it's not like a
family do you think they're infected no
look at the horses the ponies D just
fine I hope they're able by the end of
the film to find a place that's peaceful
and away from all the infected I feel
like this is like the giraffe scene oh
good point good point yeah Ellie and Jo
yeah the the music that they chose to go
with with that scene too it's almost in
in tone same that's what you were
thinking I was thinking I was wrong but
what leaving you behind all the Death
all the [__] it doesn't really mean
anything to Franken Hannah because well
she's got a dad and he's got his
daughter so I was wrong when I said that
staying alive is as good as it gets a I
feel like something bad's gonna happen
now of course I don't it's either her or
the dad or both yeah I could see a
situation where it's just killing Murphy
and the daughter surviving this movie
does thrive on bleakness so oh I was
just about to say I feel some romantic
tension chemistry it's getting late
think we better stay here for the
night is that a safe place to be can't
sleep me NE doesn't feel safe is it I
think we're safe enough
yep you don't say that in zombie movies
I'm investing you guys now I want you
guys to make it don't say things like
that Selena didn't seem to have any
trouble hey
Sela what is it what' you go to sleep
isn't the rule someone's got to stay
awake just for guard Duty
yeah bloody H must have need L of a
prescription for that lot I didn't need
a prescription I qualified as a chemist
oh
uh
I hope I was going to say I hope they're
loading the car okay why would they let
him sleep the LA the to the last drop of
oh did he leave his Bat oh do you think
that noise well they don't come out
there in the daylight so I think they
should be good they can out drive the
zombies even if it is a little honky
honk I was wrong I thought they were
definitely going to die oh we still got
some time left we like an hour left you
know they could still meet their demise
but which one are you predicting the dad
or I think he's going to have to kill I
think he's going to have to kill Selena
he's going to have to kill his lady but
he's going to hesitate and not want to
and she's going to turn that's what I'm
thinking the whole of Manchester the
whole city no fire cruise to put it
out can you see what they're looking at
cuz I can't tell oh boy now I can a
little bit wow oh that's a city on fire
wow wow wow
wow oh boy turn back turn back no no no
no no no
I'm amazed they made it this
far well they Al yeah but oh two two
tanks now siphon you're right you
right there's a helicopter there nice I
don't understand dad did they leave I
don't like this I think we should go no
maybe it's a trap Vehicles we should
check the vehicles there has to be
something where are are the
[Laughter]
fireflies can't believe it we have to go
yeah go where jeez scared the crap out
of
me more than the alarm in the beginning
it's right
[Laughter]
there
death get out of
it don't make noise don't make more
noise oh no
no come
on
dude dad are you all right odds of that
happening yeah I'm fine sweetheart no
sorry I lost my temper oh
no I love you very
much what keep away from me oh no stay
where you are keep away from me keep
away from me away me he 20
seconds away keep away oh no no no no no
no they were there the whole time yep
yep damn why didn't you guys tell away
from damn why didn't you guys tell them
you were there one male two female 8
[Music]
15 that sucks the dad passed not knowing
that he he found them yeah right is uh
the Hope was lost but he had to be the
sacrifice
to to get them safety it's really tragic
but now I'm curious how do they do they
rule through an author authoritarian
rule or just like Hey we're we're
Freedom
[Music]
Fighters the doctor Christopher eekelen
himself oh
what
what what is this
movie malakith I could be wrong I again
I could totally be wrong but I think he
actually auditioned for scarecrow as
well and Batman Begins but again I could
be totally totally wrong I think I read
that though we've got beds with clean
sheets and a boiler that produces hot
water so you can all have a
shower you look like you need one you
know who did audition for Malik though
and basically got the role and had to
turn it down at the last second mads
Mickelson really yeah I'm glad he didn't
get that role though yeah but then he
got another lame Marvel role yeah but
that was still better than Malik because
I think Malik is true more Killian ass
why how she doing she's lost her dad Jim
that's how she is is are laughing
if Comey just died in front of you I
mean I get like why she's joking around
about his question being so dumb but he
wanted to see how
like uh oh she trying to mask oh I feel
so bad now is what Frank say she's okay
she's she's tough and she's strong and
she cope just like I'll cope and just
like you'll C I don't want her dad to
cope when had had Dad it was okay it was
okay for them and it was okay for
us I know I really don't want anything
to happen to
her okay the kids in the room guys just
just saying
wait what what oh oh is she pulling away
cuz she doesn't want to get emotional
get close to get close yeah we're just
hoping for the answer to infection well
as I said before it's here though it may
not be quite what you imagined just feel
very lucky to have found you you're
quite safe here I don't trust them I
don't know why but I don't do you
something about that head rub was pretty
sus yeah had we've been lacing the
ground with trip wires and landmines you
wouldn't want to mow the lawn but if
they get in we hear them secondary to
protection our real job is to
rebuild and lastly meet
mea got infected two days
ago Mitchell managed to knock him out
and we got a chain around his
neck keeping him alive to work on the
cure for the idea was to learn something
about infection have him
teach
a he's telling me he'll never bake
bread plant crops W those eyes man yeah
and eventually he'll tell me how long
the infected take to starve to death
oh give me the chills what have we
here tinted ham tined peas tinted beans
and are they
cannibals
omelet you've prepared a feast Jones
honor of I guess sir can we see the
omelet very particular about my EXs
here see James did you notice while
cooking that these eggs are off sus
omelette I I I thought the salt might
cover the taste
sir get rid of it never over Sal the
eggs homie you ruin the whole dish if
you look at the whole life of the planet
we has only been around for a few blinks
of an eye so if the infection wipes us
all out that is a return to normality
Humanity starts a new this is what I've
seen in the four weeks since infection
people killing people which to my mind
puts us in a state of normality right
now oh no they going to hit the
landmines I don't want to EIT I want to
bury my dad he's one of the people
you're talking
about called
[Music]
[Applause]
it enemy is pretty expansive damn
[Music]
D wow that's a
[Applause]
lot damn
whoa whether these guys are good or bad
I I would still want to be there with
them they got a lot of Firepower clear
clear yeah yeah clear well protected for
sure I'm just worried that Hannah's
going to leave and want to get her dad's
body and that's going to cause a problem
you ain't going to be needing this
anymore cuz you got me to protect you
now every right
now oh
God easy tiger you don't want to go
picking a fight of me son [__]
oh who you I haven't killed any since it
began who have you killed you wouldn't
be alive now if you hadn't killed
somebody a little boy little boy that's
why that scene was there good a boy but
you had to otherwise he'd have killed
you you could have not said anything you
could have not killed that kid I
understand I promised them women 8 days
ago I found Jones with his in his mouth
oh man he said he was going to kill
himself because there was no future what
could I say to him what do nine men do
except wait to die themselves I moved us
from the blockade I set the radio
broadcasting and I promis them women oh
no that's terrible we have to go J come
on I don't I don't think they're going
to let them go though yeah you're right
about
that we got oh dude come on is this the
only way you can keep them there that's
his girlfriend dude oh
no I'm this is dude come on you guys
only good one you guys are not enemies
like stop this
nonsense
man it's the only guy with a conscience
I want to give you a
chance you can be with us but I can't
let them go that's really dark that is
disgusting I mean I want zombies to get
at least those guys not obviously killan
and Jim uh Selena and Hannah but that's
disgusting because the O has gone
insane starting the world again on the
rest of is he going to let the uh zombie
loose the one that was chained up what
would you do with a diseased Little
Island oh the Sergent they quarantined
us he's
insane so the G quartin I might have
missed the dialogue did he say that it's
not happening around the world it's just
there or think something that effect
oh
please believe me I'm not interested
these guys are
disgusting get out get move get out how
dare you disrespect that man he's the
one who created the nuclear missile come
on in your pansies do me
first use the I do not want him to get
shot is that how you're going to let
your sergeant go out Jones shoot him no
you won't you let stick me are you like
a dog
I'm going to enjoy
[Music]
this what you want
to get off get
off dude the sound
design smart dude the sound design in
this movie is insane yeah it's really
good they're making a lot of noise right
now
too making a lot did he take a shirt off
what how did he take a shirt off yeah
with the handcuffs and all that yeah
what oh I just ripped off his body I
guess it's not looking good it's not
looking good for our boy
here I'm aide he was about to fall into
a sharp object the way it was framed
there oh wow okay so the quarantine is
just specifically in that area so that's
what he was saying cuz otherwise there
wouldn't be planes flying over like that
go to the master bedroom oh my pick out
a yes sir I've never wanted to see
people get zombified so bad like I do
with these gentlemen or pigs rather yeah
this is pretty messed up come on it's
only
dressing expensive dresses these are
come on come on Killian rury just please
get back there and save
them
oh you need to leave me alone with Anna
if you want us to get changed you have
to leave the room okay smart 10 seconds
of disgustingness to get them out
smart we're going to eat these hands
okay eat these you trying to kill me is
the volume I'm making you not
care someone's on a blockade is that a
crap ton of them or is it just killing
Murphy oh he's making noise that's going
to attract
[Music]
them that's a cool shot with the rain
dropping down curious how we got the
Cuffs
off o I like that that was awesome that
was a cool shot I mean he's in survival
remember that scene they they talked
about who have you killed before he's in
survival mode right
now yeah Batman yeah seriously he also
addition for Batman he did I saw the
audition actually where he's in the
Batman Forever suit and he's Al he
actually looked good in the Batman suit
it's just is any he sounded okay too
it's just his Bruce Wayne I was not
crazy about
oh so that was actually a good choice by
uh Christopher Nolan to have him as
scarecrow and not Batman but it turned
out fine I mean he's got a phenomenal
career and him and Christopher Nolan
have an amazing relationship as apparent
by uh his casting at Oppenheimer
yeah oh
damn almost feels like the Predator
right
now is that was that a zombie we just
saw I think so oh killed the
engine
damn oh you are in trouble sir you're
screwed that is
terrible oh my God I need her to take a
machete in between his
legs oh letting Jim go yep I had a
feeling oh
we're going to get out of here stay with
there Hannah don't worry I feel fine oh
God she's chilling
[Applause]
yeah you
going get off through you two
Mo it's going back for him let's go come
on
then going to do
now
[Music]
ah now double puke on him defend stay
for
your the music though is really
good
[Music]
surprise that was awesome that was cool
yeah but you should have kept the gun
should have kept the gun that that one
smart oh I have heard this music before
on Pandora uh I listened to Movie music
on Pandora Danny Elfman radio and I've
heard this music before and whenever
I've heard I'm like this sounds familiar
and then I see 28 Days Later it's this
music oh so good it's
great she hiding in the
[Music]
bathtub it's good she had those pills
cuz she probably wouldn't have wouldn't
have gotten way more scared if she
hadn't had them yeah she'd be screaming
and and reveal their location
it's really an uh incredible
transformation for uh his character for
Jim yeah from beginning to end
mhm come
on it's almost like the roles have
reversed with him and Selena yeah from
helpless to Hero yeah just
my
just
H
whoa oh my
[Music]
God damn
[Applause]
God oh my
God oh yo oh my
God
woo oh oh cuz he thinks he's a zombie oh
yeah oh she thinks she's a monster
that's
crazy why wouldn't you say
anything that was longer than a heartbe
oh I mean it was a good moment but you
still should have said something right
it was a call back around the way you
thought yeah all bloody um guys you got
to find
Hannah glad you're kissing but find
Hannah oh thank you
gu God damn it's
okay I thought he was biting you I was
kissing her you Stone it's a long
story we have to get out of here come on
dude that gun you got rid of couldn't
help right now yep if you clear the
place out this is a good place to
actually stay just saying oh no you
killed all my boys
Eon oh
no
oh
no patch up our boy please the gates are
[Music]
loed do
it who what don't tell me that should
the movie End please don't tell me oh
okay 28 days after that or is that just
where so we're at 56 days later from the
initial beginning okay 28 days after
that okay yeah oh you thought that was
the titles imagine they just ended there
yeah was going to say you can't just end
right there
right I wasn't I wasn't ready for for
round three of of nude
killon crazy shot very like a drone shot
yeah it's like very evil Dees yeah but
they don't have Dr Monster
cam yeah clearly some time has passed
his hair has grown out yeah doesn't have
too much of a beard for 28 days it's
coming I imagine he's been shaving this
whole time oh I just thought it figured
he was in bed passed out but yeah I
guess you're right oh they're trying to
get its
[Music]
attention oh
smart
come on see it see
it
hello
wow do you want Hello or
help you think he saw us this
time oh Danny Bo hey
what is 120 is it 42 hours or 127 Hours
the one with uh 127 Hours with the one
with James Franco right is that James
Franco or uh the one where he gets stuck
on the mountain with his arm right I
thought that was Ryan
Reynolds Oh that's buried you're right
you're right then he also did uh Slum
Dog Millionaire right yeah I think so I
don't know you know more about this than
come on Aaron School me you're you're
the wizard here no I mean uh wow um that
was a very intense film um we mentioned
earlier you can definitely tell that uh
Neil Duckman and the whole team um of uh
Last of Us which we are and obviously
many of you are oh it was Naomi Harris
okay cool you're right um which uh we
are and many of y'all are humongous fans
of Last of Us obviously they didn't copy
them or anything but there was clearly
lots of inspiration from this film oh
definitely um which is awesome I can see
why yeah it's great but yeah this was
this film was extremely intense uh it
was really scary um I like too you know
whenever I I I don't watch too many
zombie things because I get easily
scared I try and obviously I try and
save them for reactions um but um I like
that they it was really balanced um what
I mean by that they didn't overdo it
with the zombie stuff like there was a
lot of uh human emotion in the film
there's a lot of character depth in it I
really love what they did with killing
Murphy's character with Jim I mean
obviously just waking up in that
hospital bed I have no idea how he got
there or how long he's been there or
whatever but um that's besides the point
but just where he you know just being in
such a confused State of Mind at the
very beginning um and just watching him
grow throughout the film um just taking
also that father esque figure you know
uh and the family Dynamic uh Father
esque Figure too of just you know kind
of the husband esque uh role you know
with nami Harris's character with Selena
and then the father figure with Hannah
um and then just growing like in in
survival mode and you know growing as a
character I I really loved his character
a lot and again just the arc he goes
through um and the transformation he
goes through I thought he gave such an
incredible performance um I'm so glad I
get to see so many I I haven't really
watched other than Batman Begins and few
other films I haven't watched too many
killan Murphy films so you know just uh
watching this and then Oppenheimer uh
when it came out uh recently in theaters
and now this like he's really good got
range as an actor I'm just so every time
I watch I'm just so impressed by him I
actually really wish we would have got
more of him and just the Dark Knight
trilogy in general um that's that's
neither here nor there though um but
he's just an incredible actor but I
really did love the setup for this story
The the World building we got I I don't
know if there were other films in the
series I I don't know too much about
this world but um I really did enjoy the
film uh again it was just so well
balanced with the horror uh the uh the
human stuff um the character stuff all
really good what did you think of the
film I really enjoyed it I thought it
was great I think from the beginning of
the movie it kind of really sets a tone
and it captures you in this setting that
things are dangerous things are lost
Hope Is Lost and the movie does a really
good job of showing destruction or
showing violence without being overt
about it like the way that The Chimps
are attacking in the beginning or the
way we see a lot of uh violence come
through through uh they have this
very I don't want to say shaky cam but
it's it's it's very like jarring it's
very like back and forth in the way that
it's it's shown you don't you know that
violence is happening and
the I'm lost for words but the way that
it's it's presented you don't overtly
see it until the very end where you're
seeing Killian Murphy like squish his
eyes out you know it's very much implied
violence and when you do see it it's
like ooh like oh this is like really
intense I think another thing the movie
does really well is what this movies
looking at it right now the credits are
playing it's uh
156 and it's wild because it manages to
fit so much plot into such a short
amount of time and I was like wow this
feels like this three-hour epic or like
this this multi-chapter thing and it is
a multi-chapter thing but it uses its
time really well and it uses the moments
we spend with these characters really
really well and I like that it has this
balance between the lighter moments and
the darker moments and you know you see
the range of of humanity over the course
of these under two hours and yeah the
way that they really presented the way
that it was shot was really interesting
you know had this kind of like old kind
of camcar look to it uh the way that the
music came into play over the course of
the film was really impact
I might be saying something that's a
little controversial we'll see in the
comment section again if you guys
disagree with me or want to rip me
totally up to you um having said that uh
well first of all Last of Us video game
second my second favorite video game of
all time as many of you know that uh the
video uh the show my favorite uh video
game TV show one of my favorite TV shows
just ever I loved it so make no mistake
don't think I'm criticizing it but one
of the things that I was a one of the
very rare things I said negatively about
it and I think GRE and I agreed on it
when we reacted to it I said they didn't
really show a lot of the um infected
which I said is fine you know you don't
have to show the infected like crazy
because this movie didn't show a ton of
infected as well but what when they did
show the infected which they did in last
of us it was incredibly in effective I
was about to say infect effective um
which but they did in a way here that
when they weren't on screen I still felt
an incredible sense of danger yeah for
whatever reason again it's not something
it's a very difficult thing to do if it
was easy to do you'd nail it every time
but for whatever reason when the the
infected were not on screen in Last of
Us for whatever reason a lot of times
there were sometimes I definitely felt
it but there were other times where I
didn't feel that sense of danger as much
as I did like and again this is a
contained 2hour film so I mean I'm not
again it's zombie it's infected versus
infected so that's why I'm making the
comparison um but again there were times
in in The Last of Us which again I love
so much but there were times I did not
feel that sense of danger when the
infected were not there and if you're
going to have long stretches of time
where there's not infected which is fine
then you better make me feel that sense
of danger and again maybe yall didn't
feel that way maybe I'm alone on that
sentiment but I always felt that way in
this film I Whenever there was no
infected on screen I always felt the
sense of danger that they could pop out
at any second or just in general we were
in a sense of danger for are the
characters yeah man I mean hey you guys
saw us we were I mean we were saying
like oh they're going to something going
to happen in any moment in between the
the positive moments and the negative
moments or like more so the uh the happy
moments and the moments of dread you you
felt that everpresent throughout the
entire film and I can wholeheartedly
agree with what Andrew said and yeah I
think it's a compliment to the director
in the writing because there was this
this hopeless feeling throughout the
entire course of the movie even when
there were the moments of Lev levity and
I think you do need those moments to
have something to root for because
otherwise it gets just like really dark
and really dreary and don't get me wrong
it was that for a lot of the movie and
there's some really messed up images in
here like I kind of said a little
earlier the fact that there were so many
things about the way that the action was
shot right but then there were so many
other scenes where it showed all of this
stuff where
the dead bodies the baby and the people
at the market or the people at the the
diner the church at the beginning and
just like oh my
God they really set the tone yeah even
if it wasn't infected they really set
the tone for what kind of movie we were
going into and yeah I I think this is
one of the better zombie movies I've
ever seen to be honest with for sure
100% yeah uh there's also two great
lessons I will take from this film um if
I ever get into it zombie apocalypse uh
work in groups of pair but I think
that's a lesson we should already know
and I got to have some Pepsi with me
you're going to survive an apocalypse
you got to have Pepsi got to have that
Pepsi yes product placement um but yeah
final thoughts uh like you said one of
the better zombie films also too uh we
did not mention although I don't want to
really get too much into it what they
were trying to do with uh Selena and
Hannah and despicably disgusting gross
man I mean awful awful
so glad they got their two there in the
end I mean I'm not even going to call
them human characters at that point I
mean you're worse than monsters monsters
they I mean yeah that's uh an
understatement there but uh glad they
got there to but again very well acted
by Christopher eckson and uh uh the rest
of the crew of guys that they got uh
those actors but yeah one of the better
zombie films uh great world building
killing Murphy absolutely killed it
great job again uh dude just always
seems to impress me with his uh
performances even brand gleon I was
really cool to see him in in the film I
me wasn't in the film too much but I was
glad again I love the whole family
dynamic in it as well um but yeah again
really good balance between the horror
um some moments of like you said levity
with some of the uh the human stuff uh
with the character moments and also some
of the comedy with the humor uh but yeah
really and the music by John Murphy I
told you guys that I had heard that um
there were scenes like to where they're
just traveling you hear that ominous
eerie music uh but also too at the end
where he's going around just having his
hero moment uh Jim and I told you I'd
heard that music on Pandora uh station
with Danny Alman radio and I'd always
wonder I'm like what is this movie 28
Days Later I'd heard of it but I didn't
really know too much about it but now I
can put in my head with that music is
from so that's really cool but all in
all I I really enjoyed this film it was
a really good one yeah yeah I'll say uh
final thoughts for me uh I love the the
music love the action uh can see now all
the inspiration from the other
properties that we've grown to love
within the zombie genre that we're all
inspired by this film seemingly or
mostly inspired by this film uh yeah I'm
happy and Marvel too yeah and Marvel
what if Avengers end game right right
right uh yeah I'm happy we had the
experience of of watching it I hope you
guys enjoyed us watching it too uh thank
you guys so much for joining us on this
adventure it has been a pleasure uh keep
in tuned for other videos that we are on
or the rest of the rejects Kon and yeah
we will see you later
peace